สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีค่ะ
กลับมาเจอกับเราสองคนนะครับในช่อง
compreter
วันนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
[เพลง]
ว่าวันจันทร์นะคะวันจันทร์ครับ
วันนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
เป็นเดือนใหม่แล้วครับวันนี้วันที่ 3
ครับเดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายนครับเดือนนี้
เดือนที่ร้อนมากๆร้อนมากๆนะครับ
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ครับ
[เพลง]
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
เพื่อที่จะเขียนเลข 1 ไม่ใช่นะ 1 ทุ่ม 50
นาที
19:50 นนะคะเรากลับมาเจอกันตอนกลางคืน
อีกแล้ว
ครับเพราะว่าวันนี้เป็นวันจันทร์ไงถ้า
เป็นวันหยุดเราก็อาจจะเจอกัน
ครั้งหน้าเราอาจจะเจอกันวันหยุดนะคะนั่ง
นี้เราเจอกันวันจันทร์ตอนกลางคืนนะคะโอเค
ค่ะวันนี้นักเรียนครูเอ๋นะ
ได้ยินได้ยินครูอาร์ตี้เนี่ยอยากจะคุยกับ
ครูเอ๋แล้วก็นักเรียนเรามาคุยกันนะคะนัก
เรียนเขาบอกว่ามาเรียนนักเรียนอาจจะปวด
หัว
มาคุยกันนะคะคุยกันเรื่อง
เกี่ยวกับความคิด
เราคุยกันเรื่องศาสนาพุทธเรื่องของการไป
วัดที่วัดมีอะไรคนที่ก็เห็นเวลานักเรียน
ไปวัดน่ะนักเรียนก็อาจจะเห็นรูปภาพที่
อยู่ที่โบสถ์หลายๆรูปเยอะๆใช่ไหม
คนที่ก็เลยคิดว่าในรูปนั้น
อธิบายเกี่ยวกับความคิดความคิดของคนที่
เวลาเข้าไปวัดตอนที่พระพุทธเจ้าเนี่ยสอน
อะไรก็จะอยู่ในรูปนั้น
[เพลง]
ก็จะมีรูปแล้วเอามาให้ดูใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับ
มีรูปที่แสดงถึงความคิดที่เกี่ยวกับรูป
ภาพที่อยู่ในโบสถ์ที่นักเรียนเคยไปแล้วก็
เห็นแล้วนักเรียนจะสงสัย
รูปอะไรอ่ะ
รูปอะไรครับอะไรคะ
นักเรียนรูปอะไรอ่ะ
เป็นภาษาพูดนะ
ภาษาพูดค่ะภาษาพูดรูปอะไรนะก็ได้นะ
ซึ่งส่วนใหญ่รูปที่อยู่ในโบสถ์เนี่ยก็จะ
เป็นรูปเกี่ยวกับที่พระพุทธเจ้าชนะ
มารครับ
[เพลง]
จะทำจะทำให้อ่าเป็นการ
ขัดขวางนะครับทำให้พระพุทธเจ้าเนี่ยไม่
สามารถนั่งสมาธิได้ไม่สามารถที่จะคิดดีๆ
ได้มันจะมาคอยขัดขวาง
ไม่ให้พระพุทธเจ้าเดินทางที่ที่ถูกต้อง
นักเรียนจำพระพุทธเจ้าได้นะคะเพราะถ้านัก
เรียนที่ฟังเรามาร้ายๆหลายๆ
หลายๆคลิปจะรู้จักพระพุทธเจ้าแล้วนะคะ
งั้นเราก็จะไปดูมันกันไหม
เหมือนตอนนี้เลยครูเอกคิดพร้อม
แล้วมารเนี่ยไม่ได้ขัดขวางเฉพาะพระ
พุทธเจ้านะมันจะขัดขวางทุกๆคนที่คิดว่าจะ
ทำจะทำดีๆมันก็จะมาแหละจะมาคอยขัดขวางคน
ที่จะทำดีเหมือนครูเอ๋ตอนนี้น้ำหนักเยอะ
อยากจะผอมลงจะได้แข็งแรงพอ
22:00 น
มันร้อนอยากกินไอศกรีมเริ่มคิดแล้ว
จริงๆแล้ว 4 ทุ่มต้องไปนอนใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
หันมาบอกแล้วกินไอติม
ดูซีรีย์
พาไปดูมาตัวแรกก่อนบ้านตัวแรกก่อนที่ที่
พระพุทธเจ้าเอ่อมาขัดขวางการปฏิบัติธรรม
ของพระพุทธเจ้าการขัดขวางการทำความดีของ
พวกเราทุกคนด้วยเหมือนกันนะครับไปดูกัน
ครับได้ค่ะไปเราไปดูกันเลยมาตัวแรกตัวนี้
เนี่ย
ภาษาบาลีนะภาษาบาลีหรือภาษาพระเราเรียก
ว่ากิเลสมาครับ
ครูอาร์ตี้อยากกินไอติมใช่ๆอยากดูซีรีย์
บอกความอยากก็คือมีอะไรบ้างครับอยากอะไร
บ้าง
เนี่ยอยากดูดู
[เพลง]
อยากได้อะไรนะเย็นๆสบายอยากได้ความสบายนะ
ครับอยากได้อยากให้ทุกสิ่งง่ายๆสะดวก
สะดวกสบายสบาย
หอมๆ
ที่เรียกว่าเป็นความอยากนะครับ
จริงๆเมย์อยากเยอะกว่านี้นะคะมาพูดถึง
ความอยากเนี่ยอยากเราก็จะถามนักเรียน
หน่อยดีไหมคะว่านักเรียนมีอยากได้อะไรไหม
อยากได้แต่ไม่ใช่อยากได้ธรรมดาอยากได้มาก
ๆแล้วก็อยากได้แล้วไม่ได้ก็
ตาย
โกรธไม่สบายใจอย่างนี้อยากชนะ
มารมารกำลังจะมาบอกมาบอกให้กลัวตี้ทำทำ
สิ่งที่ไม่ดีอันนี้คือมาที่เป็นความอยาก
ได้นะครับใช่หรือแบบนี้นะครูแอนตี้สมมุติ
นะคะสมมุติว่ามีอะไรนะมีมีคนพูดไม่ดีใช่
ไหมมีคนบอกว่า
อาร์ตี้
ก็ได้ครูเอกพูดไม่ดีขอโทษหัวตี้นะคะขอโทษ
นักเรียนนะคะต้องขอโทษก่อนนะคะ
จมูกใหญ่
ไม่หล่อขอโทษแฟนคลับครูอาร์ตี้นะคะ
จมูกใหญ่ถ้าครูอาร์ตี้มีมารครูอาร์ตี้ก็
จะพูดกลับว่ามาในตัวมาในที่อยู่ในตัวของ
ตัวตี้ก็เริ่มเริ่มแสดงออกมาแล้วเป็นแบบ
นี้ครับ
โกรธกันนะครับก็เป็นมาอีกชนิดหนึ่งนัก
เรียนสังเกตนะคะครูอาร์ตี้ไม่กล้าพูด
คือครูอาร์ตี้เขาเป็นคนดีกับนักเรียนค่ะ
ว่าครูเอ๋มีมารอยู่ครึ่งนึงนะ
ไม่
กล้า
พระพุทธเจ้าพระพุทธเจ้าท่านก็ต่อสู้กับ
มารครับด้วยการด้วยการทำอะไรครับ
[เพลง]
พระพุทธเจ้าเนี่ยมีสติใช้สติในการต่อสู้
กับหมาใช่
แค่โกรธนะคะแต่ความอยากได้ต่างๆเนี่ยนะคะ
เหมือนเมื่อกี้ที่ครูเอกยกตัวอย่างกับครู
อาร์ตี้เนี่ยครูอาร์ตี้เขาไม่มีกิเลสตัว
นี้นะคะไม่มีกิเลสมาเขาก็จะไม่พูดกลับไม่
ๆๆโกรธอ่าแต่ถ้ามีก็จะโกรธเราก็แต่ถ้ามี
สติก็จะรู้ว่าพูดไปก็ไม่มีประโยชน์มีก็
พูดไม่ดีแบบนี้บ่อยๆ
เป็นเอ่อพูดยกตัวอย่างให้นักเรียนได้ยิน
อ่ะแค่ยกยกตัวอย่างโคโยตี้ก็เข้าใจโค้ช
ติ๊กก็ไม่โกรธมาก็ทำอะไรกลัวที่ไม่ได้
[เพลง]
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ดีมากดีมากนะคะขอโทษไว้ล่วงหน้านะคะ
อ่ะนักเรียนนี่แหละค่ะเป็นการยกตัวอย่าง
เกี่ยวกับกิเลสมันๆตัวก็ทำให้โกรธนะคะ
ครูเอ๋ครูแอนตี้เชื่อไหมครูเอ๋เนี่ยต้อง
บ่อยๆ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ต้องบอกต้องบอกตัวเองครับต้องพยายามง่าย
แล้วบอกตัวเองว่า
ใจเย็นๆใช่ไหมใจเย็นใจ
[เพลง]
ความหลงก็คือเอ่อการที่เราชอบของสวยๆ
งามๆชอบฟังเพลงเพราะๆแล้วก็ลงไปเพลินไปมี
ความสุขฟัง
ๆฟังนานๆเพราะว่าชอบไงหลง
[เพลง]
ไหมคะ
ไปคาราโอเกะแล้วที่คาราโอเกะก็มีคนสวยๆ
พี่คะมาบ่อยๆนะคะ
ก็เลยชอบไปบ่อยๆเพราะว่าหลงนะครับ
สวยของน้องๆใช่ไหมน้องๆพี่
หลงเสียงเพราะๆ
ก็เป็นมาอีกตัวนึงนะครับเป็นกิเลสมาอีก
ตัวนึงที่เป็นความหลงนะครับ
[เพลง]
หลงนี่นักเรียนน่ากลัวนะเอาจริงๆนะ
น่ากลัวยังไงบ้างครับ
ไม่คือคือบางคนน่ะหลงคือหลงเนี่ย
มีหลงหลงแบบถ้าเป็นผู้ชายเห็นผู้หญิงสวย
ก็อาจจะหลงที่สวยใช่ไหมคะอ่าสวยโอ้ยไม่สน
ใจผู้หญิงคนนี้ทำอะไรได้ทำอะไรไม่ได้ใช่
ไหมคะบางคนหลงความสวยอย่างเดียวส่วนผู้
หญิงก็หลงผู้ชายพูดเพราะๆ
ผมรักคุณ
ไปแต่งงานกันจริงๆ
พอได้อยู่ด้วยกันตลอดเวลาตอนเช้ากลางวัน
เย็นอยู่ด้วยกันก็เห็นเห็นหลายๆด้านเห็น
รอบๆเห็นทุกๆอย่างก็เลยรู้ว่าอ๋อที่ที่
คิดว่าดีที่คิดว่าสวยเนี่ยไม่ไม่ใช่อย่าง
นั้นไม่เป็นแบบนั้นแล้วคือไม่ทำอาหารไม่
ทำความสะอาดอะไรอย่างนี้ว่าพูดพูดดีๆพี่
แอนตี้ขาเนี่ยเป็นอาเจ้
ยกตัวอย่างนะคะนักเรียนยกตัวอย่าง
จริงๆไม่เกี่ยวโคอาตี้ไม่เกี่ยวกับเอ๋นะ
คะ
เป็นตัวอย่างของคนที่หลงใช่ไหมเห็น
สิ่งที่ตัวเองชอบก็คิดว่าดี
ก็คือจะเห็นจากเห็นตามความเห็นของตัวเอง
ว่าสิ่งนั้นดีว่าอันนี้สวยแต่บางทีถ้าครู
เอ๋เห็นอย่างเดียวกันกับที่ครัวที่เห็น
พวกเอ๋อาจจะบอกว่าไม่สวยก็ได้แต่ขวดที่
หลงไงปวดตี้ก็เลยคิดว่า
คนนี้สวยอันนี้ดี
แต่ครูเอ๋ไม่ได้หลงเพราะครูเอ๋ไม่หลงครู
เอกก็ไม่เห็นว่าสวยเลยก็ปกติแต่กลัวตี้
หลงกลัวที่ก็เลยคิดว่าอันนี้ดีอันนี้สวย
คือการหลงนะมีมีหลายขั้นด้วยนะครูอาจจะ
ที่เราเราอธิบายน่ะคือการหลงหลงแค่รูป
หลงรูปร่างหลงเสียงนะคะหรือว่ามีการหลง
ที่มากกว่านั้นนะคะอืมหลงหลงอะไรหลงอำนาจ
เป็นคนที่มีคนเอ่อ
มีคนมีคนนับถือมีคนไหว้เยอะๆอ่าอยากเป็น
เหมือนหน้าอ่าอยากให้มีคนมาอ่าดูแลเอาใจ
ใส่เยอะมีอำนาจลงเนี่ยอำนาจแม่ก็ช่างหลง
คิดว่าเราจะไม่ตายเราจะไม่แก่เราจะไม่
เจ็บ
ก็เป็นการหลงเหมือนกันนะคะนักเรียนเราทุก
คนเกิดมาแล้วก็ต้องมี 1 วันที่เราจะโอ้ย
เจ็บ
หรือบางทีเราก็
แต่ว่าซูมเนี่ยทำให้ครูไม่แก่นะ
คะ
ก็เลยไม่แก่โอเคซูมปรับเองครูเอ๋ก็ไม่รู้
ปรับยังไงให้เป็นหน้าจริงๆ
นี่ก็คือความหลงที่นักเรียนจะเห็นจะเห็น
รูปแบบนี้นะครับอยู่ที่เอ่อผนังโบสถ์ที่
เห็นบ่อยๆว่าพระพุทธเจ้าเนี่ยต่อสู้กับ
ความหลงต่อสู้กับความ
อ่ากับความโกรธใช่ไหมมาที่เป็นความหลงมัน
ที่เป็นความโกรธมาที่เป็นความอยากได้
นะครับเหล่านี้นะครับความหลง
หลายๆอย่างเลย
ที่พระพุทธเจ้าก็ต่อสู้ด้วยเหมือนกันนะ
ครับคืออะไรคะเป็นมาเอ่ออันนี้เป็นมา
เกี่ยวกับร่างกายนะครับเอ่อภาษาบาลีก็
เรียกว่าขันธมาร
เป็นร่างกายของเราอาจจะเป็นความเจ็บปวด
ความเจ็บป่วยไม่สบายเวลานั่งสมาธินานๆรู้
สึกเป็นไงครับเวลานั่งสมาธินานๆเมื่อย
นอนดีกว่าขา
เจ็บขาอันนี้ก็เป็นความเจ็บปวดทางร่างกาย
นะครับ
ปวดหลังเมื่อยคออันนี้ก็เป็นมารที่ทำมา
มากขัดขวางขัดขวางไม่ให้เรานั่งสมาธิได้
ดีๆทำไมนั่งแล้วรู้สึกปวดมาเหมือนก็เริ่ม
มาแล้ว
จริงๆมันขี้เกียจเลยเนาะ
บางทีบางทีเอ่อครูเอกเคยนั่งสมาธิควรที่
เคยนั่งสมาธิแล้วรู้สึกว่าเอ๊ะทำไมกลัว
ที่คันทำไมคันคันทำไมคันแต่จริงๆโคโยตี้
ลืมตามาดูไม่มีไม่มีอะไรเลยแต่รู้สึกคัน
คันเป็นๆเป็นมารชนิดหนึ่งครับเป็นขันทำ
งานที่อยู่ในร่างกายของเราเป็นความจริง
ฉันก็คันไป
[เพลง]
ต่อสู้ต่อสู้กับมันด้วยด้วยการปล่อยนะ
ครับปล่อยวางนะครับ
[เพลง]
เพราะว่าอะไรรู้ไหมครับเพราะว่าจริงๆแล้ว
มันไม่มีอะไรมันไม่มีมดมากัดไม่มีแมลงมา
ไม่มีเลยเป็นความเรารู้สึกเองเป็นความรู้
สึกของเรานะครับอยู่ในตัวของเรานะครับ
ถ้าเราทำใจให้นิ่งๆก็จะหายไปใช่ครับ
เหมือนอันนี้เลยนะอันนี้ที่บอกว่านั่งไม่
มีอะไรแต่รู้สึกคันปกติรู้ไหมว่าคุณหมอ
เขาบอกว่ามันมีโรคนี้จริงๆค่ะอ๋อแล้วมัน
คันจริงใช่ไหมมันคันจริงมันคันจริงแต่ไม่
ได้คันจากเชื้อโรคหรืออะไรคันจากความ
เครียดหรือว่าการไม่สบายแล้วเราก็เลย
เครียดแล้วมันจะออกมาที่ร่างกายแล้วเราก็
จะขัน
ความคิดความเครียดของเราใช่ไหมครับ
พระพุทธเจ้า
มีสิ่งที่พระพุทธเจ้าสอนอยู่ข้อนึงที่
โคโยตี้คิดออกถึงเรื่องนี้ครับพระ
พุทธเจ้าสอนว่ามีเกิดขึ้น
ตั้งอยู่แล้วก็ดับไปอ๋อเขาเรียกว่ากฎไร้
รัก
เป็นเกิดขึ้นตั้งอยู่การคันเนี่ยเราคัน
เราแค่รู้สึกว่าอ๋อเราคัน
มันก็จะคันอยู่นะครับมันจะยังไม่หายทันที
ที่เรารู้สึกว่ามันคันนะมันก็จะตั้งอยู่
ก่อนตั้งอยู่สักแป๊บนึงแล้วเดี๋ยวเรานั่ง
ไปเรื่อยๆมันก็จะหายไป
กดข้อนี้ในการต่อสู้กับการ
ไม่สบายต่างๆที่ไม่ได้เกี่ยวกับเชื้อโรค
นะคะนักเรียน
มันก็เกิดขึ้นแล้วมันก็อยู่แล้วมันก็หาย
ไป
มันไม่อยู่กับเรานานๆไม่ได้อยู่นะคะ
[เพลง]
โอเคก็เรียกว่าอะไรนะ
ครับ
ความเจ็บป่วยความป่วยเมื่อยความเจ็บแขน
เจ็บขาหรือรู้สึกคันต่างๆที่อยู่ในร่าง
กายของเราเป็น
มารที่มาคอยขัดขวางไม่ให้เราปฏิบัติธรรม
ได้ดีๆ
พระพุทธเจ้าก็ชนะมารตัวนี้ด้วยเหมือนกัน
โอ๊ยคันโอ๊ยนกร้องโอ๊ยเมื่อยนอนดีกว่า
ต้องพยายาม
ที่ 5 นาทีพอเริ่มคันก็หยุดได้นะครับ
ครั้งต่อไป 6 นาทีนั่งไปคันอยู่คันอยู่
แต่ว่าอดทนอดทนเพราะว่าเรารู้แล้วว่ามัน
เกิดขึ้นมันตั้งอยู่แล้วเดี๋ยวมันก็ดับไป
ก็รอรออีกแป๊บนึงเดี๋ยวมันก็จะหายไปรอมัน
หายไปเนาะใช่แล้วก็ค่อยๆเพิ่มเวลาจาก 5
นาทีเป็น 10 นาทีเป็น 15 นาทีเป็น 20
แล้วก็นั่งเล่นนานๆ
[เพลง]
มีรูปมีรูปที่ที่โบสถ์เดี๋ยวเราจะมา
อธิบายรูปที่นักเรียนน่าจะเคยเห็นที่
โบสถ์กัน
นะครับ
อ่าเป็นรูปนี้ครับ
อ่ารูปนี้เป็นมันอะไรครับเป็นมารอะไรครับ
รูปนี้นะ
เดี๋ยวนักเรียนนะ
รูปนี้เป็นอะไรมีอะไรบ้างรูปนี้มีมีผู้
หญิง 3 คนอ่า 1 คนเนี่ยเอ่อ
กำลังเล่นดนตรี
ก็มีเสียงเพราะๆเข้าหู
คนนึงก็ถืออะไรไม่ทราบมีกลิ่นมีควันเห็น
ไหมคะ
อีกคนนึงน่าจะเป็นอาหารไหมคะ
ใช่ครับน่าจะเป็นอาหารครับถ้ามองเห็นก็
น่ากินจังเลย
[เพลง]
ก็
ผู้หญิงมา
ร้องเพลงมีเครื่องหอมมีอาหารมาจะไปนั่ง
อยู่ทำไมมามาฟังเพลง
มาดมเครื่องหอมมากินอาหารดีกว่า
ฟังเพลงเพราะๆ
ดีกว่านะครับอย่าไปนั่งสมาธิเลยนั่งสมาธิ
ไม่ดีเลยมาร้องเพลงมากินอาหารกันดีกว่าก็
เป็นม้าสักนิดนึงนะครับที่จะมาคอยไม่ไม่
ให้พระพุทธเจ้าเนี่ยนั่งสมาธิได้ดีๆ
พระพุทธเจ้าก็ยังคง
ฝึกต่อไป
นั่งสมาธิต่อไปเพราะพระพุทธเจ้ารู้กฎข้อ
ไตรักแล้วนะครับว่ามันเกิดขึ้นมันตั้ง
อยู่แล้วเดี๋ยวมันก็จะดับไปเดี๋ยวมันก็จะ
หายไปนะครับ
[เพลง]
พระแม่ธรณีอ๋อก็มีคนที่ออกมาช่วยใช่ไหม
กับแม่ธรณีนะครับ
พระแม่ธรณีก็บีบนะเอาผมขึ้นมาที่เก็บน้ำ
ไว้ก็บีบน้ำเลยค่ะ
เอาน้ำออกมาเพื่อขับไล่มารออกไปใช่ไหม
ครับม้าต่างๆที่จะมาขัดขวางไม่ให้พระ
พุทธเจ้าปฏิบัติว่า
ผู้หญิงสวยไปไหนล่ะคะครูอาร์ตี้
จริงๆแล้วไม่ได้เป็นผู้หญิงสวยแบบนี้นะ
ไม่ใช่นะเป็นมารที่แปลงตัวมา
แปลงตัวมาเป็นผู้หญิงสวยเอาความสวยเอา
ความหอมเอาเสียงเพลงเพราะๆมาหลอกอ่ะพระ
พุทธเจ้าให้พระพุทธเจ้าเนี่ยหยุดปฏิบัติ
นะครับ
เอาน้ำ
เอาน้ำสาดไปใส่ไปยังมา
จากมวยผมตรงนี้เรียกว่ามวยผมนะครับ
ผู้หญิงสวยๆร้องเพลงเพราะๆก็กลายมาเป็น
มารนี้ครับอ่ากลายมาเป็นมาร
ภาพนี้ภาพนี้ที่ที่นักเรียนเห็นเนี่ยเป็น
การเปรียบเทียบนะครับไม่ได้มีมารแบบนี้
จริงๆเอาถือมีดถือดาบแบบนี้มาจะฆ่าพระ
พุทธเจ้าไม่มีนะครับเป็นการเปรียบเทียบ
ว่าเป็นความอยากได้ความชอบของสวยๆงามๆ
เนี่ยเปรียบเสมือนเป็นเป็น
มารพวกนี้เป็นยักษ์ติดกับสิ่งเหล่านั้น
เพราะเราเคยเห็นใช่ไหมคะเราเคยเห็นเราเคย
ได้ใช้เราก็รู้สึกว่าเราอยากได้ก็เป็นมาร
อย่างหนึ่ง
ในรูปก็จะเป็นการเปรียบเทียบว่าเนี่ยคือ
มารที่ควรที่โคเอ๋ได้เล่าไปแล้วนะเป็น
ความอยากได้ความชอบในของสวยงามความโกรธ
ความหลงต่างๆก็เปรียบเหมือนคนพวกนี้ปีศาจ
มาหาของสวยๆงามๆดีกว่า
เหมือนกับอะไรนะสมมติครูแอน
วันนี้จะออกกำลังกาย
ในตัวขัดขวางเป็นตัวขัดขวางไม่ให้ครูเอ๋
ไปออกกำลังกายไง
หรือว่าโอ๊ยพรุ่งนี้ก็ได้วันนี้นอนก่อน
เมื่อย
อันนี้ก็มานะคะนักเรียน
ไม่อยากให้
เมื่อยนะครับไปออกกำลังกายก็เป็นมารชนิด
หนึ่ง
ทุกวันหอมไม่ดีอันนี้อะไรคะมันตัวที่ 1
เลยค่ะ
มาหลายแบบที่เข้ามาไอ้ที่อยู่กับเราใช่
ไหมที่อยู่ในตัวของเราบางทีก็อยู่ในใจของ
เรานี่แหละนะอยู่ในความคิดของเรานะครับ
เป็นมารเพื่อขัดขวางไม่ให้เราทำสิ่งดีๆไง
ครับไม่ใช่เป็นตัวมารมาทำร้ายเราจริงๆไม่
ใช่ไม่ใช่ครับ
เหมือนที่ครูเอกบอกไว้ตั้งแต่แรกวันนี้
เราจะคุยกันเรื่องความคิดมันก็อยู่ในความ
คิดของเราพระพุทธเจ้ารู้พระพุทธเจ้าก็รู้
ว่ามันอยู่ในความคิดเพราะฉะนั้นพระ
พุทธเจ้าทำไงครับก็เอาออกไปพระพุทธเจ้าก็
มีสมาธิมีสติมีสมาธิอ่าพระพุทธเจ้าใช้ใช้
ใช้ 3 สิ่งนี้ในการต่อสู้กับมารทุกชนิด
ใช้อะไรคุณรู้แล้วใช่ไหม
ศีลสมาธิแล้วก็ปัญญาไง
มีสีแล้วก็นั่งสมาธิแล้วก็
ปัญญาใช่ครับ
พระพุทธเจ้า
ในการตอบสู้กับหมานะครับซึ่งความรู้อัน
นี้ค่ะนักเรียนเรียกว่าปัญญา
ปัญญาเราก็ต้องคิด
คือต้องคิดต้องไตร่ตรองมีภาษาไทยกับหนึ่ง
เรียกว่าไตร่ตรองไตร่ตรองก็คือเวลาที่ฟัง
อะไรเวลาที่เห็นอะไรเราก็ต้องคิดแล้วคิด
อีกคิดหลายๆครั้งใช่แล้วคิดโดยมีความรู้
เข้าไปประกอบคือเข้าไปเอาความรู้เข้าไป
เข้าไปคิดอ่ะค่ะจะได้ตัดสินใจได้ถูกต้อง
ตัดสินใจได้ถูกนะครับถ้าเราคิดแล้วก็ไตร่
ตรองคิดแล้วคิดอีกนะครับ
เราก็จะมาที่เกิดขึ้นมาไม่ว่าจะเป็นมาร
ที่หลงอยากได้นะคะหรือว่าขี้เกียจพวกนี้
ก็จะหายไป
ก็เหมือนกับมารพวกนี้ที่พ่ายแพ้ไป
ต่อความรู้ต่อปัญญาของพระพุทธเจ้าพระ
พุทธเจ้าก็ตรัสรู้ใช่ไหมใช่ก็เลย
ตรัสรู้ก็คือรู้ทันรู้ทันว่ามาอันนี้เกิด
ขึ้นแบบนี้เดี๋ยวมันก็หายไปต้องต่อสู้
ด้วยวิธีไหน
ก็เป็นภาพภาพนี้ก็อยู่ที่วัดใช่ไหมคะใช่
ที่ผนังในโบสถ์นะครับอยู่ในหนังบนเวลานัก
เรียนเข้าไปก็จะเห็นภาพแบบนี้ครับคล้ายๆ
แบบนี้หรืออาจจะมีแบบอื่นก็จะเป็นการต่อ
สู้ของมันหลายๆแบบนะครับปกติยังมีรูป
อันนี้ครับ
เป็นยักษ์เป็นเทวดานะครับ
ที่พระพุทธเจ้า
เป็นคนดีมากๆอยากเป็นเทวดาเทวดา
[เพลง]
ที่เราทำอะไรดีๆแล้วเราก็มีความอยากว่า
ให้คนมองว่าเราดีเนี่ย
ครับก็คือเป็นความสะอาดอยากจะดีไง
แต่ว่าพอเขามองว่าไม่ดีแล้วเราเสียใจเห็น
ป่ะมันชนะ
แต่ว่าถ้าเราเข้าใจก็ไม่เป็นไรเพราะว่า
ถ้าคนไม่เข้าใจว่าดีไม่ดีคืออะไรก็ไม่
ต้องสนใจ
เพราะว่าเพราะว่ามันก็เป็นเรื่องของเขา
แล้วเดี๋ยวเขาก็หายไปเดี๋ยวเขาก็หยุดพูด
เราก็ทำของเราต่อทำความดีของเราต่อไปนะ
ครับ
อย่าสนใจมานะคะความอยากในการทำดีก็เป็น
มารสักนิดนึงเหมือนกัน
อันนี้ก็เป็นมันเหมือนกัน
และนี่ก็คือเดี๋ยวครั้งต่อไปนักเรียนเห็น
ภาพตามผนังบทนั่นเองก็จะคิดออกแล้วว่าอ๋อ
อันนี้เป็นมาอันนี้เป็นพระพุทธเจ้าเขาทำ
อะไรกันตามผนังที่มีรูปต่างๆที่นักเรียน
จะเห็นหลายๆแบบนะครับแต่ถ้านักเรียนอยาก
รู้เพิ่มอยากรู้มากกว่านี้ก็ทำยังไงคะ
เดี๋ยวกลัวที่อาจจะจัดรอบพิเศษสำหรับการ
อธิบายเกี่ยวกับมันว่ามีต่างๆมีอะไรบ้าง
นะครับวันนี้เล่าไป
เท่าที่นักเรียนจะพอเข้าใจได้ง่ายๆนะครับ
อ่าโอเคเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเรากลับมาเจอกัน
ใหม่ครับวันนี้เอ่อราว 2 คนก็หมดเวลาแล้ว
ครับเราต้องไปแล้วนะคะเดี๋ยวกลับมาเจอกัน
ใหม่คราวหน้าครับวันนี้ลาไปก่อนครับ
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีสวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบาย